yeah welcome a new blitz video and it's
again some guy from a distant mark i'm
sorry i was miss reading this fly cam as
no region again I actually can tell them
part was just sloppy at looking um okay
Slav I really often played the exchange
and with some success but I don't want
to do that so much on video anymore it
did fields rather dry yeah here is 395
which one I don't know both lines well I
often went for has mentioned the
exchange or lines with an early III
years own I don't dumb have any big game
experience and in these lines yeah how
does I don't despite continued here I
know there's 97 and castles Queenie to
as someone idea okay let's play Queen to
it
yeah I think this is one main line now
maybe Bishop f4 looks like a normal move
yeah in general on the idea of black in
this line is too yeah playing a sort of
hyper modern way using the bishops
before and g6 the g6 bishop often comes
to h5 fall so I'm using those pieces to
to pressurize white center and here even
long went 4 C 5 which it's not happening
too often which can be m yeah what I
wanted to say is this can be explained
by the fact that i may be playing bad
moves and normally black does manage to
play this or it could simply be bad I
don't know I'm wondering about night to
a2 if this is an idea maybe you can play
em just Bishop a five ok Manny to play
need to play at some point okay so what
now would take on c5 he probably just
recaptures I then I have Bishop b5
attacking the rook and threatening
before so on it gets gets technical
messy or just attacking the rook and
done if the place let's say that f 37
I'm playing before and windows piece so
he sacrificed material very quickly give
dollars I know I'm simply am a different
kind of player it seems i would before
i'm giving away my stuff i would run in
West a bit of time but maybe this is
just wrong so before or takes on the 8th
or work T 1 I mean all those moves on a
possible I take only eight does maybe
Bishop d3 but this then Queen III cannot
believe this Jake eh come on I still fb
form in this position yeah now i'm
attacking c5 and and at the moment i
could have also taken f7 maybe with the
idea 95 but seem down too complicated i
mean at the moment i'm a rook up so if i
return some some
some bits of material it's not not such
a problem okay so one he wants to lose
the night or maybe just a five if he
moves the night I can take the bishop
I'm a rock up just need to mention this
again okay junk windy for problem okay
there's also always this Bishop f7 I'm
not sure if I should spend this this
time okay now this also this hanging
yeah now Bishop of seven really is a
move because of 95 but there's also be
six hanging all kinds of pieces I in ok
let's take here then I'm what at the
moment to pieces up and to quote all you
can take only one at a time my extra
material so let's just come on take this
and take here and it's the a pawn on a
seven I hope this counts for something
yeah it does yeah maybe this wasn't
really working not sure computer likes
it let's eat XD ford wants to play with
compensation yeah maybe
putting the bishop on b6 and trying to
get something also an F 2 nite ce4 bit
should be 60 not too bad it's possible
but the game I think wasn't beef takes
now Queenie 8 computer with equality but
this losses Bishop f7 yeah I saw that
but I thought this this also would work
okay yeah it seems I never really gave
away much of my advantage it was just
multiple ways to to win yeah thanks for
watching